hey guys it has been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
due to the pandemic the capitol building
has been closed to the general public
for nearly 21 months so if you want to
see the inside you just have to walk
right in
a top u.s general warned in an interview
this week that china is rapidly
developing its space military
capabilities which explains that new
moon
oh well well there's a there's a
calamari uh kind of species called uh
general ackbar right and he's like you
know he's that guy it's the trap yeah
and it's fully operational
honey i can't believe you two
he has more than a he has a few lines oh
and more
it's fully operational oh have you tried
the salad bar he's got a few lines what
should we see
the roughing show is for everybody
that's what you get for approving a joke
you don't really know anything
about traces of cocaine have reportedly
been found in 11 spots in the british
parliament even worse the spots were all
under this guy's nose
came like straight to his hair yeah
according to recent reports a british
man who spent eight years building the
nation's largest model train set
initially kept it hidden from his
girlfriend and i know what you're
thinking girlfriend
[Applause]
okay more like kept her hitting him
it's fully operational
he gets it admiral
yeah
so same circle we're all we're all
learning oh getting a little less cool
authorities in saudi arabia have
reportedly banned over 40 camels from a
beauty contest after learning they had
received botox injections not to mention
implants
some throw some ds on that
a
fight broke out last week at a canadian
football league game after a player from
the toronto argonauts climbed into the
stands and punched a fan of the hamilton
tiger cats or maybe i just made up both
those team names
you'll never know you'll never know
they're as foreign to you as admiral
akbar is to me
have you tried the salad bar
hey guys welcome to the advertisement
show and
finally tuesday was national illinois
day this calls for some champagne
[Applause]
are you guys having fun
oh they seem like they're fine but oh
okay right there great
i'm glad you're having fun because the
doors are locked down y'all can't leave
now let's keep talking about the news so
on saturday a group of white
supremacists calling themselves the
patriot front marched through washington
dc carrying american flags and chanting
reclaim america and the demonstration
was caught on video
switch brings us to a segment called
some petty observations
[Music]
this group is dangerous and
anti-american but also
can we talk about their complete lack of
rhythm
look at this
what is happening what are you doing
what are these people stepping on the
ones and sevens
that is the sloppiest beat i have ever
heard in my life it sounds like he
picked up the sticks and then just
dropped them on the drums
the sounds they made are the sound
and they're going with
these guys they were protesting america
and across the street a group of
metronomes was protesting them
also
flopping around flopping like a bunch of
right-wing scarecrows have come to life
also now conservatives want to wear face
masks this photo is more hypocritical
than a vegetarian eating a meat lover's
pizza
those aren't even good face masks it
looks like you were putting on a shirt
and you accidentally put your face in
the sleeve hole
also you're trying to intimidate people
and the best outfit you could come up
with was the uniform from blockbuster
video
what are you trying to intimidate me
into doing rewinding
this is the most pathetic display of
tough guy attire i have ever seen this
guy is not sure if he wants to
ethnically cleanse america or slide into
first
and check out this man's homemade shield
where did you get that
he-man's etsy shop to fix them to do are
you fixing to fight or sled down a hill
look the rise of white supremacist
groups in america is a serious problem
according to the adl racist propaganda
is at an all-time high in our country we
should take these groups seriously but
that doesn't mean we shouldn't also make
time for some petty observations
now there's one more important news
story i want to talk about tonight
the makers of kool-aid recently issued a
recall for the beverage because it may
contain pieces of metal and glass here
to comment please welcome the kool-aid
man
[Music]
hey amber happy to be here
kool-aid man where are you oh i'm behind
this wall
oh well are you going to do the thing
what thing
the thing where you crash through it
oh yeah
no
but
that's what you're known for it's your
signature move you crash through the
wall and you yell oh yeah
oh so you think the only way for
kool-aid to be entertaining is to break
through walls and carry on like a
buffoon well sorry you will have to find
a different beverage to make your fool
oh
i'm sorry i didn't mean to offend you
you just it's just
always been my dream to see this happen
in real life
no
you know what i'm sorry
i'm just really stressed about this
recall it used to be that when you
thought about kool-aid you thought about
having fun but now i'm associated with
danger
this recall is ruining my reputation and
i'm stressed
well if it makes you feel better i still
think you're fun
you do
yeah when i think of you i think of
summertime and birthday parties than
lemonade stands i think of good times
really really and i bet a lot of other
people feel the same way
wow
you see i thought things were over for
me oh no way kool-aid man i think
they've just begun
you're right this recall isn't going to
bring me down i'm going to prove to the
world that i still got it here i come
[Music]
kool-aid man
kool-aid man
are you okay
oh no
oh god
well at least he died doing what he
loved
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you